the zeitgeist of the 90s I think is
still being written said it there's this
new fascinating technology that
everybody's getting into task bars and
email and shortcuts all mine you know it
was it was a great time
I am Nicholas P and today we're talking
with W Joseph Campbell he's a professor
of journalism at American University and
the author most recently of the
brilliant new book 1995 the year the
future began professor Campbell thanks
for talking thank you very much for your
invitation you talk about 1995 20 years
ago as a clear starting point for
contemporary life a hinge moment and the
first year of the 21st century what do
you mean by that
the netscape IPO of August of 1995 was a
moment that really illuminated the web
for for a lot of people Netscape of
course made a fantastic browser and it
was a very popular browser and the
company had only been in existence for
less than two years a year and a half
when it had this IPO its initial public
offering of its shares and the shares
were were incredibly important and
valuable and and Netscape made showed
that a lot of people could make money or
some people could make money on the
internet but more important it
illuminated as they say the web for for
a lot of a lot of people who weren't
familiar with it and weren't aware of it
yeah and it seems so long ago because
netscape's fortunes you know it you know
who I mean we might as well be talking
about a and P or something right or
Sears Roebuck exactly it was it was even
the the the trajectory of Netscape was
even briefer than that it was it was
like from 1994 to 1999 so it really was
meteoric and that her just became a
terrific property it was a terrific
company it embraced a lot of the swagger
and potential well when you talk about
it really mark Andreas and one of the
cofounders of of Netscape if Jim
Morrison was the ultimate rock star the
first real rock star Andreasen was kind
of the first web star exactly and I wish
I had said that for the book as a good
line it is and it's it happens to be
accurate too he really was and he was
only in his early 20s just out of
college a couple years out of college
when when he founded Netscape co-founded
Netscape and he and his partners
recruited some of his buddies from the
University of Illinois where he
developed a browser before going to
California to start up Netscape and
these guys made a new
that was that was wildly popular these
guys were somewhat drenched in history I
mean they were coming out of the
tradition but it was mostly that they
were they were young they were looking
forward and they really they weren't
gonna play by the old rules in many
respects that's true
mayor specs that's very true and and
they were kind of setting their own
rules and and and the internet allowed
people to do that because nobody knew
what this was gonna look like in facts
in up into the mid 90s really I thought
the internet would be a component a
sub-element really of a broader
information superhighway you know there
was also in the mid 90s I mean when you
know people are afraid of change and the
the you know the web be kind becoming
kind of commercialized and a masked
medium people freaked out in Congress in
1996 ended up passing the Communications
Decency Act as part of a telecom Act
which would have regulated the the
Internet effectively like a broadcast
network what happened that that did not
take place well that that piece of
legislation the Communications Decency
Act was declared unconstitutional by the
Supreme Court and I believe was a
unanimous decision but it was
overwhelmingly unconstitutional
recognized as such but it was it was an
early attempt by Congress to sort of
begin to grapple with the potential the
the the deleterious potential of the of
the web of the new technology and a lot
of people thought this was going to be
just a cesspool of pornography and and
nothing redeeming about it at all in
fact some of the congressmen who and
senators who were behind the
Communications Decency Act had very
little first-hand familiarity with what
they were trying to rig wait you're
telling that's not shocking is that they
have no idea of what they're talking and
yeah you have to read it or pass it to
to understand what's in it but it was a
real shocking attempt to to regulate the
this emergent technology you know it
probably would have strangled it in its
in its in its infancy but it was it was
also an attempt also a moment in which a
lot of people who were advocates of the
web you know vigorously opposed these
these measures and and ultimately
prevailed let's talk about some of the
other events how you talk about the
Oklahoma City bombing
how how would did that exemplify kind of
the end of an old order in the beginning
of the of the contemporary moment it
really did and it was it was a shocking
attack in the deep in the American
heartland an attack without warning and
it interestingly the first the initial
response the the initial reaction to the
to the bombing was that it had to have
been Middle East terrorists and the news
media really went hard on that angle so
did the FBI but it turned out to be an
act of domestic terrorism with a very
small band of disgruntled Army veterans
and basically think that I mean McVeigh
pretty much is the only person who was
directly involved and then he had a
couple of associates that's right Terry
Nichols was helping him and helped him
put together the the bomb that was the
truck bomb and that he delivered outside
the Oklahoma City Federal Building and
then there was a third sort of
co-conspirator who Michael Fortier was
writing who who knew about but didn't
say anything to run to but he didn't
know exactly when it was gonna happen
etc that's right he knew where though
they had targeted so so this is I mean
in a similar way if if part of the the
emergence of the worldwide web was the
idea that a couple of individuals coming
out of nowhere could massively transform
the world in a positive way the Oklahoma
City bombing then is kind of the dark
inversion of that you could you can look
at it that way for sure absolutely and
and in the immediate aftermath of the
Oklahoma City bombing the US government
began to put in place measures and
restrictions on American life that have
only become since then more apparent
more onerous if you will and even more
accepted I think by many Americans but
some of the initial measures that were
put in place included the blocking off
of the two blocks of Pennsylvania Avenue
nearest the White House to prevent to
thwart the potential attack on the White
House by a truck bomb ala Oklahoma City
right and and that was done without any
forewarning without named much debate at
all it was it was essentially a Secret
Service directive to protect the
president from a potential potential
attack and that effort to prevent or to
guard against the prospect of terrorist
attacks has become more and more
parent over the years and certainly
accelerated after after 9/11 and and
it's interesting that they have Lomas
City bombing much more than the first
attack on the World Trade Center which
was 93 I guess you know that the
Oklahoma City bombing had such an effect
because in fact after the Oklahoma after
the World Trade Center bombing there
wasn't really that much of an official
response there was some but but it
wasn't it wasn't the intense and
prolonged response that we saw in the
Oklahoma City aftermath that's for sure
because the Oklahoma bombing Oklahoma
City bombing had the effect of
rejuvenating some federal legislation
that really gone dormant on anti-terror
efforts and some of these measures are
very draconian and would allow for the
deportation for example of non-us
citizens on them on the flimsiest of
evidence and so some of this reaction
was was really intense and and you're
right we did not see that in the
aftermath of the first World Trade
Center bombing and then one of the other
major spectacles that you talk about is
the OJ trial the OJ Simpson trial how
does that how does that inaugurate what
the world that we're living well you
know it was it was a spectacle and it
spread kind of like a stain across the
year began in January of 1995 and and
ended with Simpson's acquittal on the
two murder charges in October of 1995
and a lasting effect was to introduce to
the mainstream consciousness the
potential and value of DNA evidence
forensic DNA evidence and this was a key
part of the trial the prosecution's case
against OJ was that they had no murder
weapon they had no confession they had
no witnesses but they did have what they
call a mountain of blood evidence ie DNA
evidence that clearly pointed to OJ
Simpson's guilt the defense's strategy
was not to challenge the validity of the
DNA evidence of the science behind the
DNA but actually to to challenge the way
it was was handled processed analyzed
and so forth in the laboratory as well
as being collected at the scene and they
were able to demonstrate just how poorly
it was done at all those levels
impugning this evidence
that made in my view OJ Simpson's
acquittal inevitable we the jury in the
above-entitled action find the defendant
Orenthal James Simpson not guilty of the
crime of murder in violation of Penal
Code section 187 which is also
fascinating that we enter into this
phase of where science kind of super
science is going to finally clear up all
the obfuscated of the universe and at
the very moment that we're learning
about how perfect DNA evidence is we
learned that there's a human factor that
renders it unusable or inoperable so
that's a bizarre kind of irony it is it
is it's an intriguing point it also had
the effect of stimulating efforts and
attempts and and and and methodologies
to collect this evidence in a proper way
so that could be properly analyzed and
properly presented in court so it
cleaned up really the the ever efforts
to to collect and process this evidence
how what do you see as the OJ's OJ trial
and the coverage of it what is its
legacy to the news media obviously that
I mean it helped mainstream that really
the 24/7 news cycle in a way it did it
did the case was though so unique and so
unlike most murder trials that it's hard
to draw a lot of parallels and a lot of
make make a lot of generalities to
generalize from this case but
nonetheless it does remain the standard
against which other high-profile
prominent murder trials are assessed and
inevitably found wanting if you think
back over the past 20 years there are
many murder trials that have been
likened to the OJ trial but really
weren't in terms of the duration in
terms of the the sustained media
interest and in terms of the
controversies to I mean none of them
really have captured those elements that
that so define the OJ trial what do you
make of the racial dynamics of the OJ
trial two because the the 90s was also
an era where it seemed that old racial
categories were kind of being exhausted
Oh J himself was considered somewhat
like an honorary white person Tiger
Woods emerged as a multi-ethnic Kaplan
Asian and yet you know the and you talk
about it in the book that the reaction
to the verdict was split almost
completely down racial lines that's
right there are a number of reasons for
those reactions and one of the reasons
why it was so vivid and so so widely
noted was that the the verdict was
announced at a set hour judge Lance Ito
the the the the judge who presided over
the trial in Los Angeles I've said that
well the verdict is in but we're going
to announce it tomorrow at ten o'clock
Pacific time so everybody new in the
country really was sort of the New York
Times called him an eerie moment of
national communion the country shut down
an anticipation of the of the OJ Berg's
not guilty guilty and a lot of people
were just gathered around television
sets and and and radio state has that's
to to know the verdict not knowing was
like an impossibility you just did and
again it's a weird book and to the to
the real publicity splash of the
low-speed chase which kind of
inaugurated the media coverage during
the NBA Finals when another vast
audience television audience was an
absolutely divert the audience in the
October of 1995 was even was even
greater how I'm sure it was probably
unlike any moment in American history
except perhaps for the first lunar
landing well everybody knew what was
going to happen but nobody knew what the
outcome was going to be and and every in
the country as I say shut down people
wouldn't get on airlines they wouldn't
they wouldn't get on flights until they
knew the verdict they the the call
volume telephone call volume dropped off
dramatically and so that so the so the
Simpson verdict was was widely
anticipated but I think some of the
important elements of the reaction and
how that was interpreted was probably
misinterpreted by the news media as a
black-white and kind of divide not all
whites thought Simpson was was guilty
and and not all blacks thought he was
not guilty so there was that element
that was not well captured by the news
media and at the same time : Powell was
was out with a memoir was doing a book
tour and was called the most popular
American of any color by one columnist
so Colin Powell was there and he was
thinking about a presidential election a
run for president in 1996 the following
year so you had OJ on one hand
the reaction seemed to be suggesting
there was this National divided along
racial lines
he had Colin Powell and the other who
everybody you know black and white were
sort of coalescing around so which is it
and and then we had Bill Clinton as the
first black president right so I mean
it's an interesting definitely a hinge
moment it was and Clinton was was was
very worried about the prospect of :
Powell mounting a campaign against him
: Powell eventually decided in November
of 1995 that he wasn't gonna run for
president he didn't hear the calling he
said let's talk about another political
event that that takes up a chunk of the
book the Dayton Peace Accords and you
talk about you use Peter Brian arts term
about the the hubris bubble what did the
Dayton Peace Accords like what what did
they signal in American culture well
this was a moment when American
diplomacy muscular American diplomacy
brought an end to the worst conflict in
Europe since the time of the Nazis since
the end of World War two and that's the
the war in Bosnia which 100,000 people
were so were killed in in this conflict
it's two and half year three year
conflict one that the European powers
couldn't resolve despite many efforts to
try the United States through the good
services of and the talents of Richard
Holbrooke who then was an Assistant
Secretary of State brought the the
representatives of the three countries
of all Bosnia Serbia and Croatia they're
the heads of state essentially the
presidents to Dayton Ohio to the
wright-patterson Air Force Base and kept
them there essentially for three weeks
and radio silence until they thrashed
out an agreement the end of this long
war in Bosnia and that was the first
clear major success foreign policy
success of the Clinton administration
and it really did give that the
administration a left it really boosted
the administration's ability to to feel
good about itself to bring about a
successful conclusion to a to Thorian
and this was at a time where the people
were talking about the Incredible
Shrinking presidency and Bill Clinton
after you know he has lost Congress and
the control of Congress in the 94
election so he was kind of evaporated
and this helped bring him that's right
it really did that and the government
shutdown of mid-november 1995 which
Clinton outmaneuvered essentially Newt
Gingrich in the House Republicans and
and sort of came out on top at least
public opinion polls suggest that the
Clinton got the better of that of that
shutdown so that happened in
mid-november 1995 in the third week in
November there's the Dayton Peace
Accords the the cores are initial to
Dayton signed in Paris in amid great
pomp and circumstance now Clinton did
agree to send 20,000 US troops as part
of a larger peacekeeping force NATO
peacekeeping force to Bosnia which was a
very politically risky decision it
turned out well because no American
casualties were but but they need to
talk about it too as the hubris bombing
this is kind of what inflated the hubris
right that the legacy then is that okay
well we're America and you talk about
how Clinton didn't quite use the term
American exceptionalism but he brought
it back invoke that you know all we have
to do is come in and start making people
talk and we can we can fix any any
problem in any country anywhere
essentially and without us it's not
gonna it's not gonna work it's not going
to happen without us peace in Bosnia is
not going to it's not going to last
without our presence of troops there
it's not gonna it's not going to happen
so this this notion of American
exceptionalism you're right he didn't
call it that but that's exactly what he
was referring to really took hold and it
undergirded this this this sense of
hubris this hubris bubble that began
expanding in the aftermath of Dayton and
and it was accompanied by a muscular
approach to foreign policy a willingness
to use force to achieve foreign policy
ends and we saw this in Iraq in 1998
when Clinton ordered the bombing of Iraq
to supposedly degrade Saddam Hussein's
weapons of mass destruction arsenal you
also saw in the coast of our war of 1999
and we certainly saw it in the aftermath
of 9/11 with the us-led invasion of
Afghanistan and then in Iraq sorry in
2003 so this hubris bubble kept
expanding until it did burst and the
insurgency that the United States was
totally unprepared for in the aftermath
of the invasion of Iraq one of the other
and you know and this is the last long
section in the book which
it deals with among other things things
that happened in 1998 but started in 95
Clinton meets Lewinsky talk about you
know obviously they met in 95 what is
the enduring legacy of of that whole
story you know it's it's I think that
that legacy is still being written I
think part of the legacy is the is the
sharp political cleavage that we see in
that in the country today in terms of
the partisanship Democrat Republican
left and right and it's it's it's it's
it's a mistake to say it was because of
the only because of the impeachment wars
of 1998 1999 that we have this this
political division today but it
certainly was a contributing factor it
certainly was a contributing factor the
impeachment votes the votes to impeach
President Clinton in December 1998 were
clearly along party lines
the two counts that Congress approved
that the House approved most Republicans
favored most Democrats opposed and same
with with the votes to convict or acquit
him in the Senate in February 1999 most
Republicans voted to to convict him and
most Democrats voted against him it had
no chance ever of getting to the
two-thirds level that was needed but
what's intriguing about 1995 in this
whole scandal was if it were not for the
government shut down at mid November
1995 Clinton and Lewinsky would have
never had an opportunity to get close
she was a nominal White House intern at
the time and because of the shutdown the
partial government shutdown most White
House staffers as well as most federal
employees were sent home or stayed home
they were furloughed and into this
breach at the White House entered the
cadre of interns who filled the the jobs
of answering the phones and doing
whatever has to be done to keep the
place functioning Levins pay you even
mentioned in the book that a sheep
lewinsky believe that Clinton's actual
White House girlfriend had been furlough
so that's right she was under the
impression that he had another
girlfriend and she was like a temporary
fill-in there at furlough her assignment
was in the chief of staff's office which
is down a corridor from from the Oval
Office
had it not been for that shutdown she
would never have had the opportunity
Thanks
you know people talk about the
and I can remember when Clinton took
office people were like oh well he's not
he's not taking the office of president
seriously and there was a whole flap
about like his weak military salute to
people and things like the exact meant
yeah but you know and then the the
Lewinsky incident really you know
changed the picture of the president I
mean everybody knows that presidents
have you know behaved poorly in their
personal lives but this was inescapable
and it was on TV and is that part of its
legacy that it's you know in many of the
things we're talking about here
Authority kind of established Authority
has taken it on the chin and in many of
the offense that you talked about in 95
is that part of the legacy of Clinton
meeting Lewinsky it could be I think
another element of the legacy is that
it's it's very we know it's very
difficult to impeach a president and
we're not going to be doing this again
for the kind of misconduct that Clinton
was guilty I mean he clearly perjured
himself in a federal deposition and and
probably committed obstruction of
justice - which are akin to the crimes
that Richard Nixon was forced out of
office for I mean he really obstructed
justice and in the Watergate scandal but
that was an order of magnitude it seems
more serious than than what Clinton was
was and of course he he resigned before
he was going to face all of that - which
is part of the fascinating lesson of
Clinton is that you know just stick it
out I mean like if you can outlast your
enemies you know you you can hang on no
matter what true enough and and he had
the good fortune Clinton of having
enemies who were so bungling and so
inept they were in effect became his
allies I mean it's session I mean he ran
against George HW Bush in 1992 for the
presidency Bush by then was kind of out
of touch and perceived widely as such in
1986 for re-election Clinton ran against
Bob Dole who was like 73 years old and
not the most vigorous Republican poet
even who had pledged only served one
term exactly and then Kenneth Starr who
was the independent counsel who
investigated Clinton's misconduct
also was sort of tone-deaf and didn't
really understand who didn't have the
the political skills or the why leanness
of of Clinton and it was
clearly outmaneuvered by is the real
legacy of the Clinton presidency is just
keep doing what you're doing if you if
you have the skills to to be able to
maneuver that way I think so and I'm not
sure Oh bomb is quite as politically
skilled as Bill Clinton I mean he is
you're right plowing ahead and as his
popularity seems to be rising a bit but
we're talking about Clinton in the 60s
approval rating 60% approval rating in
the late in his second term we don't see
that at all with with Obama when will we
know that the 90s have ended we need a
little bit of a critical distance to
make that determination it could have
been that it ended with 2001 some people
make the argument that the 90s began I
don't necessarily subscribe to this was
an intriguing case that the 90s began
with the fall of the Berlin Wall in 1989
signaling the end of communism in
Eastern Europe and then the nineties
continued until September 2001 with the
terrorist attacks of that day so that
that could be you know a way in which
you're looking at the 1990s the 90s are
so popular in some popular cultural kind
of way that it seems like there's you
hear often references to the 90s are
back and and the 90s there are there's
90s nostalgia that seems to be pretty
stronger than what explains that in in a
way that you know I was thinking about
as we're talking the 1950s particularly
by conservatives in the 1980's the 1950s
became this decade when everything was
great you know women stopped working
which was good for conservatives men you
know people stopped getting divorced the
economy boom there were no problems kids
were respectful of their elders and yet
if you go back and look at the 1950s you
know it's a decade of Catcher in the Rye
of the wild one of rebel without a cause
of why Johnny can't read of growing up
absurd of the beatniks and of absolute
moral and mental and urban chaos what
what decides you know and then other
decades like the 70s also seen as
generally negative but there was a lot
of really fascinating stuff going on
both economically in terms of
deregulation of airline
railroads and trucking as well as a lot
of lifestyle experimentation which
people that would see is a good thing
you know how what what makes a decade
seem would be seen through rosy colored
glasses or through very dark light
that's a very good question again the
passage of time it helps helps explain
that but the zeitgeist of the 90s I
think is still being written you're
right the zeitgeist of the 50s was it
was this Placid time when everybody was
sort of at peace and and and prosperity
reigned you have some of that too with
the 1990s looking back particularly the
second half
that you know the country is largely at
peace the economy is booming there's
this new fascinating technology that
everybody's getting into you know it was
it was a great time but there are other
folks Charles Krauthammer for example
calls the 1990s a holiday from history
mostly saying that to to excoriate
Clinton and his policy on on terrorism
international terrorism but still I
think holiday from history is probably
an exaggeration to it was it was not
that simplistic obviously there were
there were a lot of important major
issues that we're still grappling with
today I mean everything from from
foreign policy issues to to you know the
the rise of the Internet right yeah and
I mean we're gonna be talking about net
neutrality which is 20 years later is
another attempt by the government to
regulate or constrain the Internet
according to its vision of what is what
is fair and right absolutely absolutely
so these attempts to to label a decade
tend inevitably to be simplistic
superficial and and misleading and so I
don't think the zeitgeist of the 90s is
yet written and it's certainly not a
holiday from history it's certain wasn't
the time in which you know nothing much
happened and we were kind of like
beginning to set ourselves up for the
for the terrorist attacks of September
11th well we will leave it there
the book is 1995 the year the future
began we've been talking to Joseph
Campbell of American University thanks
for speaking with us thank you very much
it's a pleasure for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie